vladimir region prison hospital number
33
is where alexi navalny has been
transferred
the lawyer for the 44 year old
opposition leader says after 20 days on
hunger strike
drinking only water his client situation
is only getting worse he looks sad
so sad he's getting thinner thinner than
he used to be
he walks with difficulty he has no
strength
alexei erlich is one of navalny's
doctors he's not been allowed to see his
patient
but going by his latest records says
navalny is at risk of kidney failure
his health is already in high danger now
and every day the risk increases
the longer a person stays on hunger
strike the deeper the metabolic
has become and the harder it is for them
to get back to normal
because a long hunger strike leads to
damage of all the body's organ functions
navalny is serving a two and a half year
sentence for embezzlement
that he says is trumped up he was
arrested in january
after returning to russia from germany
he'd spent five months there
recuperating
after almost being killed by what the
germans say was poisoning with a banned
nerve agent his case has added to
moscow's international isolation
russian diplomats have been expelled and
the u.s and eu have imposed
sanctions for allegations of cyber
hacking election interference
spying and the occupation of crimea we
are very much worried about the
health situation of mr navalny yesterday
we issued a statement and behaved at 27
member states
asking the russian authorities to
provide
the health care he needs and they are
responsible for their safety
navalny says he'll stay on hunger strike
until the prison authorities
allow him to see his own doctors alexei
navalny supporters
have asked people across russia to come
out and demonstrate
on wednesday evening this square in
moscow is supposed to be one of the
places where they're going to gather and
it's already
being fenced off russia's police have
advised people
not to come out and protest bernard
smith al jazeera moscow